McIlwain I'm bummed casual garlic garlic
right come around Apple's iPhone either
like a visible an app see with clarity
subtle my my name is Gary Thomas I've
been telling you accountability i'll
tripoli given a pedigree Sabine and a
pleasure my faculties putting the work
time jernard the moving furniture 11 I
don't think people realize how much
money I'm leaving on the table for
humanity for my legacy for the good
stuff you know being an interesting
human being is a thing yeah and so like
the biggest thing I think that people
are the biggest downfall is lack of
self-awareness like who wants to sit
there and say well I'm just not
interesting cute smart clever you know
enough yeah we all have different paths
right like you know we're a different
path so I think the mistake is lack of
self-awareness the next biggest mistake
is lack of patience and I think that I
think like a patience manifests in a
couple place save the horrible version
of lack of patience which is like
somebody's completely tone-deaf yeah
they think they're Gary Vee or they
think they're [ __ ] Beyonce and it's
like no two people on American Idol
we're like not doing it for sick they
like literally think that they're
[ __ ] unbelievable then they sing in
their [ __ ] yeah so there's that but I
really think there's another version
which is I think a lot of people that
actually follow me because I kind of
suffocate the other crowd out pretty
quickly there's other places to go if
you want to be completely tone-deaf yeah
which is the people that are actually
slightly on meth etic and they realize
you're trying to be an influencer and
they realize there's some baggage along
with that and they're actually
empathetic to what their friends are
saying behind their back and the problem
is you don't go from zero to a hundred
and one day yeah you have to be able to
eat the [ __ ] of the voices you have to
be able to accept the voices you have to
be empathetic to your buddy who's like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are what
the [ __ ] are you doing you have to be
you have to be able to do that that's
what the early pioneers of reality TV
did
that's what the Kardashians did you have
to be able to when everybody says you
suck to know that you're not and that's
hard yeah especially when you have to go
a year or two or three before you
actually get to the place to prove them
wrong
that sucks and that is like yep I love
being an underdog I hate that I'm
starting to have my moment I like that a
year ago when it was still I knew it was
coming and a lot less people knew it was
coming
yeah I think a lot of people are
starting to know it's coming so intense
wisdom North Star this entire
conversation yes the intent you know
this is how novel like when you post a
snip thank you
know for all the admiration of every
like 24 year old that's coming my way
there's a big part of me that doesn't
like it because I like being
underestimated I could never sell the
things I make fun of yeah I feel like
I'm not selling
some documented I'm aware that it's
leading to things it feels a lot better
than the people that pay me are
[Music]
you know I don't feel good selling a
$9,000 course any industry where the
majority of the winners and players are
doing things that are selfish for
themselves and not for their clients is
a vulnerable industry that was the
high-end wine business years ago that's
why one there that is the engine see
world today in marketing that's why I'm
winning there and neither one of them
combined isn't bad as football agents
are to their players I mean it is the
part of people fundamentally confused
about me is for some reason maybe forgot
that I spent 13 years building this to
run this business and didn't say one
word to anybody ever about anything yes
I'm actually a businessman I moonlight
as Gary that's it Gary these Batman you
know what I mean kind of thing like
phenolic that's that's the Keynesian
part about me that's why I'm pushing the
kids to build actual things and patience
if kids in the cutlery of surgery you
know what I'm not saying
we're perfect cuz I'm 41 you're 33 and
they're 22 there's a perfect oh can you
believe how young you feel right now
yeah you would have never thought that a
20 tale or no the end got good news for
you you didn't feel the same at 41
that's it love that's the [ __ ] game
at Yankee Stadium Portuguese wonders
here a man and I started doing anybody
work it's gonna be cool - I think 40
hours of it something and then I tend to
sound like okay that's it maybe they
will reply I don't know maybe we'll put
it stuff and then really completely
above my expectations and it was funny
there was a couple of friends of mine
they were like heavy and you would send
them an email asking if you wanted no it
did it I got a chance work it's always
the answer is inside more more more just
do you just do maybe you get something
maybe you want that's right you know
what's funny you probably never would
have got an answer to the email crush
but yeah you know what I mean though but
the fact that each of the way but you
list you did obviously you love doing it
that makes it fun it's always better
when that's the case
cool man so what's happened have people
ping you like what's what's been
happening about it yeah
appeared
and doing my own thing now video I'm a
I'm a be rocker Tyler yep fortunately
for people for your cell phone I am
exposed exploring both exploring the one
rock concert over to you talking green
to answer for TV but junk I can do this
for you nobody thinks nobody's that's so
crazy you said that yesterday no but
nobody is doing what we're doing
no nobody has a shadow maybe some people
do block it right and when you vlog your
stuff yet be like we don't have to be
you're like Kati and the quality and
entertainment is there okay but most are
annoying most people aren't going to do
well being shadowed either you have to
have the to what's here I'm gonna [ __ ]
you gonna ready [ __ ] you're gonna hi I
want to build my personal friend I want
to be my own I get it MP you can do both
no no that's right I know that all right
I do marketing for myself I mean we do
market you know I don't know you know
with weapons the invite us all like
Asian people know you ain't college I
said this obscure but I've been back
here I'll say like I don't need you
really really I've been checking
voicemails when you leave them then
delete them shadow reasons I've been
reading all these headline I get second
page meeting on my deadlines a couple
steps away cause cause cause that's like
more and more more right in in my summer
listen I come come on girl me there
really does elevate was like close
enough to say we really got you invested
off a secondhand jesters like it's just
there okay cool great let me know Frank
I'll talk yes you my holy hearty I was
going to eat into the ATM if I could get
2013 10 24 to 10 yeah I wanted to be
p.m. why you would get clips I don't
want it like that dirty I just I just
took a bunch of twenties out of the ATM
second no I don't want to do that no no
sometimes you just go with your
intuition
thousands to the [ __ ] moon because
the far serve better than if he shot
this high because we shoot in the clouds
and end up on a roof the words of wisdom
from Uncle Jack here grandpappy Gary
older bro Gary I know there's some old
time is watching I got you your buddy
Gary in Jersey super close to Edison New
Jersey right now makes me happy
feel no Jersey Bible I don't think dome
always coming I'm a bracket like a
haunted sister hunter but mm man it's
all I ever wanted that sweetest thing
I've ever known as quantitative things
is managing efficiencies one of the
advantage to your point and I've been
thinking about this one of the
advantages that team Gary has is if
you're not doing something which is
almost never but if you're not but but
if you're not I'll lose my [ __ ] if
you're not making make me a [ __ ]
animated gif [ __ ]
I don't like it Steven Spielberg's works
on Team Gary I'll be like where's my
[ __ ] insulated when I volunteer
that'll get you buzzing they go and
click it if you made it they keep on
coming back it's something different
with it it could be like fashion high
low
the number one thing happening in
fashion right now it's been happening
for a while is women mainly butts Menzer
like like so we're a $1,700 pair of
jeans and a $1 t-shirt right and the
handbag seven bucks and the glasses are
17,000
we we need that that is what I have it's
not the Babin Iraq are so special it's
that that's the religion your you might
make an animated movie you might make an
animated gif and that's that and so as
long as the animators love but as long
as the animator with down time is like
pocket I'll just make some public
seventeen animating things today and we
can put it out on social like I know
what to do and I've got to change a lot
of rules but I want you to be bought
into the religion everybody said I'm
going we're fixing the airplane while we
fly it
by the way by the way by not by not
taking a stop in Providence Rhode Island
to fix something and then Kansas City
Missouri we've laughed the world 15
times well everybody's still fixing
their brakes and [ __ ] Wichita
parallel now this big mop a series of
meetings as a lot of you guys know we
bought pure while women's publishing
company modern media company very
excited about the acquisition and team
Brian Holland CEO unbelievable Mary Kay
editor-in-chief unbelievable really
excited by the strategy we're putting in
place like it's good there was a good
big purchase
it's going to continue the process of
winning there's only the Union yang the
great promise of the world that I saw
isn't going to happen because people
don't have the self-esteem to put
themselves out there to have a real
consolidation bang up so I tell young he
needs to be part of and at its world in
that that well shouldn't produce a lot
more content I've got something
literally bigger down we can't miss
twice if we're going to put people in
these slots the output has to show like
there's a wit look I've really there's
something I'm seeing that I'll excited
about like let's just produce a shitload
more content and having it paid for of
course of course we're in if we produce
it Oh baby I know what I'm doing right
now we're losing on both sides i defined
it as emotional intelligence
self-awareness empathy gratitude are
absolutely three things that emerge
immediately to me when I think about
them and I think it may affect the
amount that's in the environment really
and the workplace more than people
realize that is the game the honest
activity whole family is not there
recognize I just think it's my queen of
them I say what a long [ __ ] war ago
so I mean if you're a book so I think
it's why I'm able to be really if I
wasn't empathetic people that troll me
and don't believe in me and think I'm
the bad version of a version that I am
would have stopped you can doing that
opposite get here just have two great
meetings with the pure well team on two
major different objectives now we're
going to have dinner together the teams
continue to bond when you make these
integrations you have to massively over
index in the beginning of any important
accretion when you buy a company besides
it's pure well which is a sizable
business the biggest business I've ever
bought
you've got to triple down and so you got
to do 9:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. dinner
sometimes we do Valken early and the
passion and focus and so time to be to
be on that's when I get serious good day
I can go in it you know guys killing it
and like love you for your comments
enjoy it and I love you guys back when I
say I'm an anomaly I can I'm not
pathetic to what people may think about
that but to me it's a bigger sense of
responsibility to make sure that people
that are looking at me don't become
crippled we're trying to replicate it if
they don't have like natural energy on
my ass their passion for what it is
[ __ ] passion them just really just
knew how it was going to play out
you know this that's the nicest way to
say yes it ain't chicken if you made it
I'm just on my phone check your metrics
from my followers on baby number two
take your wifey through her follow up
this is